مرحبا بكم من جديد الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
تيك توك شوتشيو اكد في شهادته امام
الكونغرس الامريكي ان الشركات تاخذ
المخاوف الامريكيه على محمل الجد مضيفا ان
شركته لن تسمح بالتلاعب ببيانات
المستخدمين من ايه جهه بل على العكس
شوتشيو قال ان حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين هو مسؤوليه شركته وان الشركه
ملتزمه بذلك
ونفى رئيس تيك توك الذي يضم 150 مليون
مستخدم في الولايات المتحده وحدها مشاركه
شركته للبيانات مع الحكومه الصينيه وجاءت
شهاده رئيس شركه تيك توك امام لجنه الطاقه
والتجاره في مجلس النواب الامريكي بواشنطن
في محاوله لتهدئه مخاوف الكونغرس بشان
الامن القومي وبحسب الكونجرس فان السلطات
الصينيه قد تخترق هواتف الامريكيين عبر
تيك توك ومن جانبها حذرت الحكومه الصينيه
من بيع تيك توك وقالت ان الخطوه ستقوض ثقه
المستثمرين الاجانب في الولايات المتحده
فيما وصفت تقارير اعلاميه مواجهه تشيو
بالمعركه العبثيه واضافت التقارير نقلا عن
مساعدين جمهوريين في اللجنه للصحفيين في
وقت سابق ان رئيسه اللجنه الجمهوريه تريد
فرض حظر على تيك توك في امريكا
نتابع ايضا الموضوع من بكين مع الصحفيه
نادر رونج ومن سانتا كلارا عبر سكايب ايضا
معنا الدكتور حسين العمري استاذ العلوم
علوم الحاسب في كليه مشيجن مرحبا بكما
ضيفي الكريمين ابدا معك ضيفي في بكين
بدايه عن هذه
الجلسه لمدير تيك توك امام لجنه الكونجرس
ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه لجهه مصير تيك توك
الحضره ام البيع
اهلا ومرحبا بكم اعتقد يعني حضر شامل هذا
يعني
ليس هناك احتمال كبير لهذا التوجه لان
هناك
مستخدمون
الامريكيون كثيرون
للتطبيق تيك توك يتجاوز مئه وخمسون مليون
يعني مستخدم والكثير من المشاهير الانترنت
يعني ايضا تعارض هذا الحظر وكذلك هناك بعض
المحلات تبيع يعني معظم مبيعات سيئه ايضا
من ترويجها على هذا التطبيق فهذا اولا
هناك يعني اصوات ومعارضه من داخل الولايات
المتحده من الاصوات المواطنين
من المواطنين الامريكيين وكذلك
يمكن ان نرى هناك التعهدات التيك توك يعني
وضعوا امن حمايه امني المعلومات في المقام
الاول وقد اعطى كذلك كل البيانات معلوماتي
الى نقله هايله الى شركه امريكيه او الجهه
مستغله الثالثه للمراقبه
واعتقد يعني هذا الحذر الشامل يعني ليس
هناك احتمال كبير ولكن البيع
الشركات هذا يتوقف على يعني الامور
القانونيه والسياسيه فيما يتعلق بالقوانين
الصينيه والامريكيه
نعم طيب دكتور حسين
الحديث الان عن حظر تيك توك هناك من يقول
انه صحيح هناك بعض الدول حضرت تيك توك
بشكل تام ولكن رغم ذلك هذا زاد في شعبيه
التطبيق وهناك وسائل تقنيه تتمكن يتمكن من
خلالها المستخدمون من التغلب على اي حظر
لتطبيق تيك توك هل تعتقد ان الحظر مجدي
امام الشعبيه المتزايده لتيك توك
السلام عليكم رمضان كريم
الحظر بالنسبه للحظر يجب ان نكون ان نميز
بين الحظر للاستعمال الحكومي والحظر
للاستعمال الافراد صحيح
ما حصل هو كله حظر للاستعمال الحكومي في
امريكا في الولايات الامريكيه في نهايه
2022 وفي المانيا وفي اوروبا وكندا وهذه
كلها لم تمس الافراد لان هذه تدخل في
عمليه حريه الكلام وحريه الاستماع وحريه
لا تقيد الحريات فالذي حصل هو يمنع من على
موظفي الحكومه بانزال التطبيق على اجهزتهم
ابدا هذا ما حصل والان هم يريدون ان
يحضروا تطبيق بشكل كامل نعم فهذا شوف هذا
يعني انت تسالني هل الحظر مجدي ام لا اولا
الحظر لن يحصل انت عندك 150 مليون امريكي
يستخدمون تقطع
اكثر تطبيق 2021
والتطبيق الكاب كات كات
200 مليون السنتين
[موسيقى]
السيارات محاربه فالعان هو هذه نقطه
النقطه الثانيه ليست اموال النقطه الثانيه
يعني هم الان يريدون ان يخيفوا المستهلك
الامريكي 150 مليون الصين تتجسس عليكم
الصين لا تريد ولكن انا الفرق انه عندي
اشياء عليها نختار من يتجسس عليها هل
الصين امام امريكا يعني هو نعمل الكل
يتجسس يعني الكل يخترق خصوصيتك فقط يعني
انه المساله اذا كان امريكي ام صيني
الحل الثاني هو
الحظر يعني تسيطر لامريكا ايضا لا يفيد
المستهلك شيء فالحلول من ناحيه المستهلك
لا على قدها مسائل الحلول هي بينهم كبار
ان امريكا الان خليني اقول لك كلمه امريكا
هي من يسيطر على المعلومه انت عندك يعني
لو كان صحيح السيد تسيطر على تيك توك وهو
على فكره يعني حسب التقرير لعشر صفحات
قرات التقرير عشر سبعات المقدم من الرئيس
التنفيذي يقول التطبيق غير موجود في الصين
اصلا والشركه ليس لها فروع في الصين
الشركه في لوس انجلوس وفي
[موسيقى]
فعلا ان الحكومه الصينيه لا تستطيع الوصول
الى بيانات المستخدمين دكتور حسين نعم
هناك مشروع
ظهرت فيه تيك توك
[موسيقى]
هذا بحيث كل المعلومات الامريكيين مليون
تمر فقط تحت سيطره اوركل وسيطر امريكيه
كامله ولكن
استاذه اسالك هنا يعني الصين لا تريد ان
يحضر تطبيقها تيك توك في الغرب بشكل كامل
يعني في امريكا وغيرها من الدول الاوروبيه
لكن الصين تحضر فيسبوك مثلا وهي وسيله
التواصل الاجتماعي فلماذا يعني حلال عليكم
حرام علينا
لا لم تحذروا الفيسبوك انا استخدمه دائما
وانا استخدم
استخدم الواتساب فقط تحتاج الى تطبيق
في الصين انت بحاجه الى وسيله تقنيه لتخطي
الحمايه لفك الحمايه او تغيير الموقع لكن
نحن نستخدمها في السن بشكل حر يعني كل شخص
يستطيع ان يعني يستخدم دارك هناك
المستخدمون من الصين الصينيون كثيرون على
الفيسبوك
نعم نعم طيب
لابد ان ناخذ تعليق ضيفي من امريكا يعني
انه هل تعتقد يعني انه في الصين هناك حريه
الوصول بالفعل الى وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في 30 ثانيه لو سمحت هو الصين
2017 انه كل الشركات المطلوب انها تزود
الحكومه
الملكه تيك توك
لم تتلقى اي طلب بالالفين 2022 كل سنه
تنشر مع الطلبات الحكوميه التي جاءت من
الخارج من الحكومات الاجنبيه ليس بينها اي
طلب من الحكومه الصينيه
الرجل يقول ان الشركه ليست صينيه هو عشرين
بالمئه مستثمرين صينيين عشرين بالمئه
الملاكين و60% شركات
وصلت الفكره ولكن انتهى وقتي في بانوراما
اذن من سانتا كلارا دكتور حسين العمري ومن
بكين نادي الرونك شكرا جزيلا لكما
ومشاهدينا شكرا لكم انتم على كرم المتابعه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]